there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey everybody out there it's
the first episode of 20/20 I mean I know
we did like matinee and stuff like that
but this is that this is the first
actual episode episode 177 yeah we've
been doing this for what how many years
now uh [ __ ] three yeah probably
maybe you've a little bit longer than
that because I think we started it in
the summer of 2016
oh man [ __ ] all this I'm retired no you
don't know I'm having fun we still got a
lot of [ __ ] we got to talk about that's
what I mean it's like I still have like
two years from topics two people
recommended that I'm probably there now
this topic in particular I I can't
remember if somebody requested it or if
you said something about it I mentioned
this a long time I think you mentioned
it a long time ago and I wrote it on the
list and then like it just kept getting
shuffled around on the schedule and
stuff like that and then I was like you
know I mean because I like to have like
true-crime and then like just kind of
more paranormal or weird stuff and I
like to you know kind of switch them out
so it turns out that most of the topics
that people have recommended are true
crime so I'm running out of like
paranormal stuff and like weird stuff
and everything so it's like I finally
got around to this topic yeah even
though it was probably like two years
ago that you mentioned it there's
another one I came up with you know
doctor go ahead and tell the audience
but I want to eventually talk about the
killdozer yeah you were just talking
about this the other night about the guy
who made his own tank tore it out of
town with it well yeah pretty much the
whole story maybe I'll talk about
killdozer a lot of people's people know
about killed us I was like the only
thing that I knew about the movie named
killdozer
but you know I guess that's why they
called it that after the movie but yeah
we wanted to do
show about burlesque in house now we did
a show a long time ago about Aleister
Crowley it wasn't like a real I think it
was awhile back that we did it but the
one that we did on Aleister Crowley I
feel like it was just like fun facts
about Aleister Crowley it wasn't like a
super in-depth know anything so I
thought well it's not really repeating
because I'm mostly talking about the
house yes we're gonna talk a lot about
Aleister Crowley because he is obviously
it was obviously his most famous
resident Zeppelin but yeah there's a you
know Jimmy Page in the house for a while
there was like weird [ __ ] going on like
even in the area like him before the
house was built and it should be noted
too that I didn't even do this on
purpose but it's actually relevant to be
talking about it now because I actually
didn't realize this until I started
researching but burlesque in house
essentially burned down in 2015 and then
there was another fire in July of last
year in 2019 and as of last month
December of 2019
they've started restoring it like a um
like the burlesque in house foundation
like it's a non-profit and they bought
it and they're gonna restore it and like
open it to the public like as a museum
so they just started doing it um they're
not really sure that you know they think
it was like a kitchen or something like
that now the one in July of 2019
was I don't know if that was the main
house or some of the outbuildings they
think that was arson but the first one
the one that you know mostly destroyed
the house in 2015 I think that was just
an accidental fire because there were
people living there at the time although
they weren't home when it happened yeah
hopefully it wasn't those insurance
wires getting cross no I don't think so
I mean like the people that have been
living they had been living there for
quite a while and you know
yeah but uninsurance wires man they
burned down many a [ __ ] all the
business over time they have yeah and
the thing about it is like despite its
reputation I'm always like kind of
surprised when I look at it because wait
well when you kind of hear but it's like
oh dude Aleister Crowley lived and it's
like on the shores of Loch Ness and all
this other kind of stuff I always I
always like before I saw pictures of it
I always am
it would look like hell house you know
from the movie room the 70s like with
all he's like turrets and [ __ ] like that
house from the legacy yeah I thought it
would look something like that it
doesn't look anything like that it just
looks like a regular it was it was
originally a hunting lodge um so it
looks kind of like it's it's big-ish but
it's not huge it's only like one story
and I think what makes it look weird -
is that just that big like terrace with
the sand and everything like that which
Curley did for you know magical purposes
but it just makes the house look really
odd like it doesn't have any like
landscaping or at least think it would
look like the damn cover off that first
Led Zep cough to cover that first Black
Sabbath album that which stand out there
yeah that's what I was expecting it just
looks so house right Church I camera it
looks so pedestrian
yeah just like given its reputation yeah
over the years but yeah so it's like
there's enough like cool stories about
it that I thought we could make a show
about it and talk about Aleister Crowley
and his time there and like some of the
people that live there subsequently it
might just be British prog rock dudes
get high in that house though well I'm
sure there was some of that but yeah so
it's like this is actually a really
interesting topic I find it a really
interesting topic so we'll kind of get
into it in a bit however before we do
that I have a whole bunch of shout outs
yeah we have like a whole bunch of new
patrons yeah I asked I asked for patrons
and that you asked and they came yeah
thank you very much guys yeah thank you
continue to ask every single give us a
picture will show you I can never break
that $500 a month mark yeah it's like we
got almost up there and then like we
lost a couple because of like yeah
holidays and people's financial players
and stuff which you know I understand
that there's enough of you now that if
anybody who joins up even just a couple
of dollars makes a difference now well
yeah that's because we have so many
people on YouTube and I think we I don't
even know how many people we have the
people that are paying us the big bucks
they've been with us for a long time
they've been playing that a long time
that they started that back and we
didn't have any patrons of them be like
a thousand subs
yeah it's crazy we're almost to 8,000
now yeah which that's that's crazy I
don't think you become a real channel to
hit like 10,000 yeah but it's like we're
getting there slowly yeah I mean you
know like I said we're kind of in a
quarter to my channel much cooler that
way but yeah so we got a lot of new
patrons this week so big thank yous and
shout outs to odd cat Janet Jamie aka
black marigold and Mary Ellen who I
think was a patron before and then we
lost her for a little while but then she
came back so thank you guys very much
also thank you to Jessica and Melanie
for their paypal donations Melanie gives
us PayPal donations all the time also
our friend Sophie and I think it was you
Sophie she sent me yeah she asked you
God
yeah okay she was the one remember she
sent me that Ian Brady book which I'm
reading I'm actually I'm at the chapter
now where he's talking about the mad
butcher of Kings Barry run do we do a
show about that we did didn't we I think
so I mean I remember writing about it
it's like I get confused about like what
we did for the show like what I did in
my books would you like that that's like
the guy in um it's Cleveland right that
was going around like chopping people up
and draining all their blood and like
leaving them in the slums it's like back
in the 30s yeah yeah you did that one
I'm pretty sure I did a show about that
but yeah it was a centered around those
homeless camps yeah yeah um but yeah so
Sophie sent me another book check it out
dennis is gonna be super into this it's
Katherine rams lands hook about BTK look
Dennis it's a book all about you yeah
you know that's from interviews that I
did Rose in prison you know I know
everyone who really wants to know what
my deal was and I tell the whole story
because I deal with you know I'm a very
interesting guy lot of charisma and you
know I was a lot of people you know they
could read this book and turn their life
around and I'm just you know because you
know I have so much to teach the world
you know in like how not to be well you
could look at that word get a like
you're gonna look at that way everyone
but I was pretty good for the community
I mean
friends even testified to church the
work that I did with church and you know
and I made sure that the grass was cut
you know and that everybody's grass was
the proper height in the town I put a
lot of dogs behind bars you know
important you know I was a well-rounded
man
yeah well-rounded character you know I
did a little bit of everything and you
know you could learn from me you
certainly did yeah I know you like it
[Laughter]
you know Jenny you got some big old
boobs I know it's like I'm surprised
every single bad wake up every morning
look I'm knock that [ __ ] off Dennis
risky well yeah he's attention to him
you pay attention to Dennis he starts
talking and you know starts thinking
he's important and he starts taking over
it's that next natural gangster in him
you know okay just gotta take over over
situation you know I'm not grandstanding
but yeah so it's like now now it's like
when I read that BTK book I'm gonna read
it entirely like in my head it'll be you
doing Dennis Rader yeah so the whole
thing is gonna be reading it is I'm
gonna be reading about like all these
horrible murders that'll be like
snickering to myself because it's like
your impression of dentistry yes ma'am
all right so um also I wanted to say to
you because some people have asked about
it the witching hour show that I started
doing where I'm reading like scary
stories and stuff I'm gonna start
putting those up on Thursdays um I don't
know if I'm gonna do like the early
access thing or is it because I'm
already like you know already if the
three shows a week and do an early
access and stuff and I get confused
about what - is read that Doris you got
all available how many got six stories
you're holding back on watching well six
episodes those are stories in each other
yeah because each each episode has at
least two stories like depending on how
long they are like I think the first one
that I put up I think that was four or
five different stories because those
were really short but I have some other
ones that are
stories three stories four stories
whatever so I have yeah I'm done with
all the ones for this month and I think
one or two for next month even Jenn and
I found out there's a whole scene for
that on YouTube yeah some people are
related that and like and what I'm
things have million hits on well when I
put up the first one and it's like I you
know I like reading scary stories and I
have to you know read most some of my
stories like for my audio books and
stuff like that so I just figured why
don't I just like read a couple more and
then like make shows out of it
because I have to read my stories anyway
and you know I'm already in the booth so
so I might as well like you know have
another show come out every week cuz
they're not really that time-consuming
need you to sound editing is kind of a
pain but other than that it's like not
really that big a deal and um yeah and
it's like the when I posted the first
one on Thursday like I got like a lot of
comments like you know a lot of our you
know regular listeners and stuff we're
like oh this is really cool and it's
like they listen to it when they're
going to sleep and stuff like that so I
guess a lot of people do that I got the
idea like over Halloween because I found
this one channel and I can't read what
it's called now but I subscribed to it
but it's just a guy reading his are
mostly like true stories like from
reddit and stuff like that but I was
like wow this is kind of cool like you
know you just kind of listen he just had
like real simple graphics and stuff it's
not anything complicated but you know
he's just like telling these creepy
stories and I'm like man I kind of like
listen to people reading creepy stories
his yeah a lot yeah I you know say I
listen to whole like a whole bunch of
those like on Halloween night you know I
mean that's that alone would be good
advertising yeah for the show and books
and stuff you know and just yeah it's
almost like a good you know way to get
your name out there well yeah and like I
said I figured since I had to read
stories anyway like I might as well you
know cuz and the more content you put up
it's like I know we already do three
shows a week but that way algorithms if
you put a lot of stuff out yeah so we
don't want to just put my [ __ ] out
we'll put out stuff - yeah I'm only
gonna put out stuff that I think is like
good I'm not just gonna put [ __ ] up
there just for the sake of putting it up
there I also think is kind of good
to have each little thing as like a for
a different target audience so that way
you have a real well-rounded show you
can bring in people from different
interests but they're the different but
same yeah and like I said that's why I
keep them all in different like
playlists too because then that way it's
like I'm like beard board games where
they do it yeah yeah yeah that's what I
was thinking too because it's like they
have like a whole bunch of different
shows and it's like maybe you like some
of their shows but not the other ones
you know and so you can just like watch
the ones you like and not really watch
guys you guys you guys need to check out
beer and board games if you nervous I
love well and I love like it's a blame
society name as a channel yeah lady's
name is channel view yeah they do
um beer and board games i they have like
four or five different shows because if
they do chad vader and they do it's like
a bunch of comedians movie reviews and
yeah welcome to the basement is a you
know Matt and Craig like and they just
like talk about movies and that's I
really really like that show and very
drunk and play board games is really
funny it's usually like Matt and Aaron
are the two guys and then they used to
have like a rotating cast of other two
people and they just like sit around and
drink that's where we got the name for
our cat baby cookie baby cookies from
it's a character character on more games
it's like it's a little naked doll that
comes in every now and then like it
comes in naked makes a little drop to
make it drunk she's not drunk I don't
think she's just she's drugged by half
the time but sometimes she is but yeah
so she comes in and like she's white but
she speaks Ebonics yeah it's funnier
than we're making it's gotta go
but yeah it's like some of the games are
better than others like they do a
different game every week sometimes they
do more than one like on one show the
best ones are the like kind of the dirty
ones like they're ones that are kind of
like um you know like what's like the
cards against humanity' like ones like
that or sometimes people will send them
like really really cheesy ass games like
that I didn't even know existed like you
guys the other day they did one that was
Kenny G like keepin it sexy I think was
it I was like somebody made that get
like somebody mass-produced that game
and it's like it was like the lamest
game ever the I mean the episode was
hilarious just
the [ __ ] game your bid and I couldn't
believe that anybody [ __ ] made it
we gotta send them one of your games I
was thinking about it because you can
actually sponsor like on their patreon
you can sponsor an episode and they'll
play if you send them like your game and
like however much money it is like a
sponsorship then they'll play you guys
you got a bias plot
yeah that's smart actually yeah because
that way you're not inundated with free
[ __ ] free plugs yeah you got pay gotta
pay for that evidence yeah it's one of
the spec they're games
it's one of their things on patreon like
you can like it's a certain amount I
don't remember how much it is like it I
think it is it's quite a bit of money
but um yeah and you can sponsor an area
look at their patreon man those dudes
are [ __ ] making Bank
well they've been doing it for I mean
welcome to the basement they've been
doing that for eight years chad vader
they might have been doing for 10 or 11
years so they've been around a long yeah
and they're like in the thousands of mod
and i mean some of them like matt sloan
and stuff like that he's like they're
famous yeah he's kind of like kind of
famous in the you know minneapolis air
like comedian type of area and like he's
actually like written for TV shows and
[ __ ] like that so it's like so they're
not random yeah they're not just like
random people they're kind of like
well-known within their circles but
they're making [ __ ] good money on
that program yeah but I mean they need
to focus in on the money but well no but
I don't do that [ __ ] for a living they
they do but they do an incredible amount
yet a lot of work because they do it was
over 10,000 a month that they were
making yeah because they do at least
four shows a week if not more they also
do live streams pretty much all the time
you can watch like all their beer and
board games like you can watch the whole
unedited thing like if you go to their
website like you can watch the whole
thing live because and not see like all
the [ __ ] they cut out because I think
they film two at once and so they're
there for like four hours or something
so you can like watch the whole thing
but it's like say and they have
constantly have like new products on
there you know you know patreon page
like they have all kind of coasters and
all kind of like branded they have their
own beer and all this other kind of
stuff so it's like they're really if you
really put a lot of work on it if you're
into stuff like MST 3000 you'd like
[ __ ] blame society there
kind of like that kind of style yeah and
Matt's alone is like a big mst3k fan
actually welcome to the basement is a
lot like that because they both kind of
sit on a couch and watch a movie like
every week and and kind of riff on it
you know in a similar similar kind of
way but then they talk about movies like
seriously like what movies they've seen
and like people send them movies to
watch and stuff like that it's kinda
cool they're high-caliber people man
very educated they're not simpletons
like me well that's why I like welcome
to the basement because it's like Lacey
yeah they've seen like everything and
also Matt is like into a lot of the same
music it's made another classic silver
screen [ __ ] they know all the [ __ ] go
that story is just like something from
my yeah they know like every you know
all of these pretty much everything I
mean other than like some niche stuff
cuz I don't think Matt is super into
horror maybe say he doesn't really know
like a lot about horror movies but he
knows about a lot about other types I'm
down in that basement I got some badass
record records too yeah he has like
millions and millions of records and
he'll like turn a record out so you see
the cover like every episode is a
different it's a different well he's got
that one yeah he's got like every record
ever all the good albums he had him yeah
and as and like a lot it's cool too
because he said has like really eclectic
taste like I said he's really into like
you know Punk and kind of alternative
music back in the 80s but he likes
pretty much everything he has everything
so alright dub since that was like we
think this digression we get around to
talking about get around tomek zaleska
now Scott the Belasco house not the
Belasco house this is Valeska yeah it is
in Scotland
it's actually a they considered a manor
house like I said it's not gigantic I'm
not sure exactly what the square footage
is it's actually on the southeast side
of Loch Ness which we will come to in in
a bit yeah at this house okay let me go
ahead and be testosterone infused but
you know with with this situation I have
to tease this this is the house that you
heard all the stories about that Led
Zeppelin was living in it used to it
used to be used to belong to Aleister
Crowley and this is evidently the house
where you're supposed to sell you it was
haunted and you could sell your soul to
the devil in this house to become famous
that's the big that's the legend that's
the basic legend I heard
this [ __ ] when I was a little kid okay
in California remember my old look met
my babysitter named Kimmy yes he's like
14 foot one yeah he look like a little
Princess Leia
yeah and you know I can remember her and
her friends talking about this [ __ ] when
I was a little kid yeah because they
were they'd play Led Zeppelin albums
right and you know when your little kid
things are impression you know yeah yeah
and I could remember that they were
saying that they had a whole house you
know where a wizard magician lived there
and that they would sell their soul to
the devil they're not good I mean this
is talked about a couple years before
Star Wars and [ __ ] but I I had enough I
had enough awareness to know you know
what magic was and selling your soul and
the devil and I was gonna Wow and
somehow there was rock and roll was
involved with this yeah and you know and
cute teenage girls get out Iranian all
the best things and all the best things
in life yeah they had the blacklight
posters and everything you know and the
black lights and burn an incense there's
price smoking weed was too young to
probably realize well I
Cali California rolled that way yeah I
mean pass me around like a teddy bear
and [ __ ] hug on me and [ __ ] these
[ __ ] 1415 twelve thirteen year old
girl because you're such I was like
seven yeah you know he looked just like
Damien there just needs to tell me that
they look like Danny he's that little
boy from the omen you always make me
laugh when you do like yeah so yeah yeah
so this house is in the Scottish
Highlands about 21 miles south of
Inverness
now before Aleister Crowley even moved
in there before he was even born before
he was even conceived there was all kind
of weird [ __ ] that happened like around
the area where the house would later be
built now the parish of Belle Eskin was
actually kind of formed incorporated in
the 13th century now originally on the
site where burlesque in-house would
later stand there was a Kirk you know
which is kind of what they call the
church over there and a cemetery which
had been built at the parish now there
was like all these ministers that ran
the parish and [ __ ] like that and so
over like many many years but even like
back then there were like legends about
this place like there was this one
minister named Thomas Houston or Houston
I'm not sure how you pronounce it
who died in 1705 now he said apparently
there was this wizard that lived in the
area and he would like I don't know why
but he would like bring the dead back
out of the graves like at the graveyard
like just for shits and giggles I guess
he's like look I'm raising the dead so
it's you know well you know necromancy
was always kind of like though sure that
was that was what sorcerers were trying
to do and where they when you're talking
about magic or any kind of spirituality
it always culminates in bringing back
the dead yeah I mean Jesus was bringing
back the dead you know there's all kinds
of necromancy is all these stories this
even goes back to Chinese lore about
people bringing back the dead
I can't believe it this new rise of
Skywalker movie where they're bringing
back the dead and that people were
surprised and I'm like what told you in
a new hope that this was sorceress yeah
and you know and they even called
obi-wan Kenobi an old wizard a crazy old
wizard that's what is space wizards and
yeah krome answers you know and then
they went with it in the prequels two
equals were talking about yeah he could
cheat death he could even keep the dead
from dying you know yeah that was like
the whole point of all I can win another
thing looking for to either become one
with the force and and then hold
yourself together and come back as a
ghost like him to be immortal or to
raise the dead or to keep people from
dying that's zombies yeah vampires yeah
it's exactly what they're talking about
I can't live like anybody anybody that's
bitching about that in the news like did
you even see this yeah do you understand
how like it's not even like the outside
like the extended universe or anything
like that this was it was in the movies
yeah they're trying to yeah this
wanted to [ __ ] bring back the dead
well like you said that's something that
like evil like quote unquote evil they
all do it is their movie necromancer's
and stuff like that that was that's kind
of their thing
yeah even big trouble a little China it
was a ghost tried to reincarnate himself
that's coming back in the dead yeah yeah
and that's essentially so you know back
in you know the 7/3 sixteen 1700s
apparently there was some local wizard
and he would like reanimate the corpses
in the graveyard and it was this one
ministers job Thomas Houston or Houston
who had to kind of like put him back in
there I guess that was like his job so
that was how the story went so this is
even before burlesque in house was even
built this was like the same area
now this store there's another story to
that the kirk or the church actually
there was like a whole congregation in
there like doing their little churchy
thing and the church caught fire and
burned down and killed everyone inside I
don't know if that's true or not but
that's how the story goes that that's
the the church was destroyed and
everyone died in it
now there's also there's a burial ground
like on the site and the remains of the
original Chapel are still there and that
there's also a hut that's called the
grave Watchers hut that's where the
person who was the grave watcher
he wasn't like looking for zombies he
was looking for grave robbers because
people would come and like you know dig
the bodies up steal [ __ ] steal bodies
whatever so he was he just saved the
stayed in this little Hut and like
watched out for people doing that so
burlesque in house was actually built on
the site of the burndown Church it was
first built in the 1760s by Colonel
Colonel Archibald Frazier and as I
mentioned before it was built as a
hunting lodge now evidently that's
sheriff I'd start leaders day of this
but a barely current Archibald Frazier
he chose this particular site to build
the house because he wanted to piss off
this other guy named Simon Fraser who
I'm assuming was a relative of his Simon
Fraser was the 11th Lord Lovat sometimes
nicknamed the Fox
probably not because he was sexy
that's what yeah I think that's probably
why because I've seen paintings of him
and he wasn't all that
so apparently Simon Fraser had given his
support to the Hanoverian side during
the Jacobite uprising in 1745 and I
guess his land was like kind of either
surrounded where bol Eskin house would
eventually be built or was like you know
butted up against it so Archibald
Frazier's to want to build this house
right here just to like piss you off
because they were like on differing
sides in the war now fun fact
later Simon Fraser was executed in
London by beheading and one of these
stories that goes around about Valeska
house is that sometimes you can hear
Lord Lovitz decapitated head rolling up
and down balls
I don't know if anyone's seen it or not
yeah I guess a rolling head has a
certain sound that everyone can
recognize [ __ ] head is that the first
thing you would say he's like oh I can
hear the squish like when his neck but
still I can hear the face so I'm
assuming he's some people must have seen
it yeah because otherwise why would that
be the first thing that your [ __ ] and
and Lord loved it wasn't even executed
in Scotland he was executed in London so
why his head would have like flown all
the way back to bless kin house to roll
up and down the halls I don't really
know but that's like one story that's
kind of told about the house and this
was you know before Aleister Crowley
even thought about moving in so the
hunting lodge was actually the Frazer
family lived there and they kept like
building out onto it like it expanding
it until about 1830 as I said it's all
one floor it has four bedrooms a kitchen
a servants bedroom like an attic room
that's kind of like over the kitchen
then it has a lounge a drawing room
which is really really big and it has a
library also underneath the house
there's a tunnel that leads from the
house to the cemetery
not entirely sure why but they put it
there back then so no so they lived
there until then now Aleister Crowley
bought it from the Frazier family in
1899 so let's talk a little bit about
mr. Crowley mr. Crowley I figured that
was those gonna calm me yeah that's why
I said it spontaneous [ __ ] - I didn't
know that was coming I think that we
staged that instead I just think for
musical human humor like chill watch
that MST and I don't get hardly any of
it and then all of a sudden they'll do
it some kind of musical humor and I
start rolling and she looks to be like
what the [ __ ] cuz I respond to that real
well lowbrow humor and people singing
dogs but that's like like that's the
nice thing about MST is that yeah they
do like a lot of like hybrid like a lot
of like obscure humor yeah do you know
they're talking um like I get a lot of
it cuz a lot of it's not as highbrow as
you think because a lot of its just kind
of like obscure like shows and commotion
around watch a bunch of TV and a bunch
of read a bunch of books even though
they're talking about half the time
that's true but then like they have that
but then they also have like like you
said music like funny songs fart jokes
yeah stuff like that so you know it has
something for everybody that's what's
nice about it and play and another thing
that's nice about is you can watch
episodes over and over again because
there's so many jokes in there
can't get about that you can't get them
all and it's like you know so they have
like really good rewatch ability hey web
and mannose hands of fate
live show that we saw from I don't think
I've ever laughed mannose hands the
faith is the best show that they put on
I think they've done some good I'll ever
look like giant spider invasion - but
it's like they've done some good ones
but yeah but I mean Manos it's just such
a it's such a good one - like [ __ ]
riff on because it's one it's so weird
and - it's like there's real there's
long stretches of silence so it's like
there's a lot of room for you to like
put your own jokes in there and show my
editing and yeah and the editing is just
you know because they can
we film for like 30 seconds this is a
camera that's almost good so that it's
weird see yeah that's what I always
thought yeah I was cause I actually kind
of liked the idea and it actually has
like a really creepy atmosphere I don't
know if they intended it it's creepy in
a way they didn't I've seen photos or
something it is and like they and like
they made that like when they did it
first on MSc like way back in the joel
era that was one of the you know lines
that I remember from it's like every
scene of this movie lose every frame of
this movie looks like someone's last
known photograph yeah it's like wow they
nailed it that yeah that's exactly what
it's like but it's just you know I
honest almost like to see somebody I
don't know I almost like to see somebody
remake it cuz like I said it's kind of a
cool idea
yeah but I don't know if you could
capture part of the reason why that had
that tone is because it was it was so
incompetent because it was incompetent
yeah on a really low tech equipment yeah
yeah I mean and that was why it came off
that way if you did that with modern
equipment it would just be lost in the
[ __ ] shuffle it probably would just
be like just look really going yeah I
think maybe that's kind of why people
still respond to it now it is because if
there's one thing it's it's just weird
and they didn't mean for it to be weird
and that makes it weirder yeah you know
what I might need to get back to the
show they think we're stalling because
we don't have any material we do though
I have like whole and this is an
interesting story I need to stop [ __ ]
with her and let her let her talk about
it I know see because that's why our
last show about Lizzie Borden was like
hours long because you just kept like
interrupting and going off although a
lot of changes a lot of people tell me
that me [ __ ] with you is the show I
know that's why well that's why I was so
bummed out like why you couldn't do the
matinee with me because we could have
you know we we were gonna talk about
uncut gems cuz I wanted you to talk
about it but it's like I just that's
that's okay yeah yeah cuz he had to go
yeah take your mom to the doctor yeah
hey my doctor yeah so Aleister Crowley
actually born Edward Alexander Crowley
in 1875 now he came from like a wealthy
family so he was kind of one of those
guys that he didn't really have to get a
job ever you could just be one of
those guys back in the day that you
select lay around and write poetry and
yeah what was funny back in France did
it you know I mean this is they had a
noble class these are these are supposed
to be like the rich people they put them
all welfare yeah that's funny they feel
kind of are yeah they need to do that
here well guess they kind of do yeah I
was gonna say yeah oh that should they
do for the corporations and stuff is
similar yeah they're you know they're
getting all the tax breaks and they're
getting all the [ __ ] contracts and
[ __ ] in a way yeah I mean my broke ass
is like everything yeah you're had the
[ __ ] balls to put the rich people on
welfare so those [ __ ] didn't have to
work well some of them a lot of them
were I mean the royal family is like a
different story but a lot of those kind
of like noble families and stuff like
that it's just their families have money
so it's just that passed from you know
family to family with France I remember
reading that you know if you could you
could prove you were this and that and
become a count then you would just them
you'd get can't you get money from the
king yeah you didn't have to work then
what you started yeah okay yeah your
account all right put on a powdered wig
and come to the party like yeah and then
they would like it whatever you put you
in charge of something yeah I mean like
you're the count of you know Montecristo
there's no money Chris Knight but you're
like in heat that's what that stores all
body maybe that there was no money
Christmas but like the count or the
[ __ ] you know of the [ __ ] box behind
the [ __ ] the box and then you you
know you get like a couple [ __ ] you
know like a couple hundred crowns a
[ __ ] month you know something say
some [ __ ] every now and then go pop in
there and look at that dumpster behind
the McDonald's and make sure that's how
the Marquis de Sade was yeah he's
basically on welfare he but he didn't
you didn't live like a rich man per se
at the end of his life I think he was
living in a [ __ ] barn yeah if I
remember correctly spent a lot of his
time in jail and Bastille and [ __ ] for
right net dirty ass [ __ ] and breaking
making people mad he did making people
me a [ __ ] pervert
we haven't done a show on the Marquis de
Sade talk about Marquis one of these
days just remind me I'll write it down
that's because I don't even think he's
on my list
he was subversive [ __ ] I think
he lied about a lot of this
but well mostly what he's known for is
his erotica he was writing that erotic
and handed it out through the bars of
the deal and the end it was selling and
they were printing that [ __ ] [ __ ] he
was did you see that movie that was made
about that called quills it's actually
pretty good I remember it being pretty
guys I read some of his stuff man it's
wild it's hard to believe it does 1700s
yeah I mean it's just like some [ __ ]
weird-ass sadistic [ __ ] porn that
you'd you know this goes to [ __ ] why not
they dudes had imaginations back there
they figured all that [ __ ] out revenge
porn going on [ __ ] mutilation and
stuff yeah humiliation it's just like
some BDSM thing yeah like I said Taylor
the oldest time I that's been going on
since humans were able to like write
down what they what they were into yeah
but yeah so currently had a similar
situation like he came from a wealthy
family he grew up in work shirt England
and ended up being you know lots of
things he was a writer a cultist
astrologer painter poet lots of other
things also an expert Mountaineer and a
master chess player so later on
obviously he's best known for you know
all of his writings and for coming up
with his you know religious philosophy I
guess you would call it but he wrote the
confessions of Aleister Crowley magic
without tears and the book of the law
now the book of the law was actually
written he said that it came to him from
an entity called Aiwass in cairo egypt
so he was like dictated from this like
spiritual being I guess so he wrote that
in 1904 now that is actually the sacred
text of his occult system which is known
as Salima and people still practice this
nowadays it's essentially like I don't
wanna say it's like Wicca but it's kind
of like a similar kind of thing where
it's like you know do what that well tis
the whole of the law and all the stuff
yeah
but you know that's what that's just
what the writings were like what yeah
what the system was more like
Scientology yeah you know you came to
him and they teach you some [ __ ] and
then you used to pay him some more money
to teach you some more [ __ ] and then you
know they could keep you paying money to
to go up and up in the levels yeah in
Tolima you know that was I don't think
it was like that at the beginning but
that was just part of this it's just
kind of all devastating robbed into a
[ __ ] scam yeah to where we talked
about that a little bit when we went
into Aleister kerlix we talked about the
order of the Golden Dawn and all that
kind of stuff Carly wanted money man you
can't you know I mean he had [ __ ]
[ __ ] to do you know about drugs all
kinds of stuff you had to buy and yeah
well yeah you got a buddy four trucks up
yeah and he'd like to party you know
money had to come from somewhere and you
know you had to pay him to teach you how
to be a wizard that's really what you
know what that evolved into yeah and but
if you but I would argue that if you
could get people to pay for that yeah
then man yeah well see that's you know
that's exactly the same thing that l ron
hubbard did that's what Scientology is
all about yeah pan to go up in levels
yeah you level it up you're talking
about breathe you know and they have to
write some kind of [ __ ] spiritual
manuscripts and things to read and
things that you have to do in order to
level up yeah and you know you got to
pay each time you do it you know they
call it ot going up the bridge yep
Scientology's you guys know what I'm
talking about if you guys don't know
what I'm talking about go back and go
look at our Scientology with it with the
angry gay Pope he'll tell you that we've
done three shows with him I think
through two or three shows I can't
remember
oh my I'm back on again it is difficult
to control he runs it runs off at the
mouth I know somebody else that does
yeah okay so even though Crowley was
kind of like you know obviously the
press it was like a good story it's like
you know they call them the wickedest
man in the world you know the Great
Beast
give a game all these other [ __ ]
names right into his hands they really
did because I do feel like even his you
know theological writings his religious
philosophy and stuff I I think people
focus too much on that do what that well
follow blot and it almost makes it seem
like you know it's like it's the kind of
[ __ ] that likes Satanists used to get
where it's like oh it just sounds like
oh you just do whatever the [ __ ] you
want to yeah and not worry about the
consequences that's not what they're
saying no at all um so I feel like in a
way like he was misunderstood but then
in a way I think he thought it was kind
of like funny too and he kind of like
encouraged he [ __ ] it too he just
well yeah as he's going along it was
artistic it wasn't a logical system yeah
all the way you know I mean there would
be a lot of contradictions in it you
know what I mean now I can't go in there
I don't know so well enough where I can
tell you exactly where to look to find
these contradictions you know I mean but
I've read it's kind of [ __ ] and I know
that kind of gobbly [ __ ] yeah kind of
psychobabble and poetry yeah
I'm not saying it's bad is it it's
spiritual writing you can get away with
a lot in spiritual writers because
nobody knows write anything it's not
like anybody has about that on lockdown
he was writing that [ __ ] on the
influence of trances and you know and I
think I know crazy [ __ ] yeah drugs you
know he believed what he was saying he
did I mean and you know when when we get
into a little just in a second like when
he bought burlesque in house and stuff
like that I mean he really did seem to
buy it for a particular purpose and it's
like he really did want to do this
ritual that you know was like kind of
involved so he really did seem to want
to do that so he really believed what he
wrote I think yeah to an extent he was a
prototype l ron Hubbard I mean I would
say he's trying to start a new religion
yeah and make a bunch of money at it and
get a bunch of power
yeah and l ron hubbard actually you know
borrowed a lot from crowley oh yeah big
part of it a lot of the same concepts
yeah and this it's really instructive to
look kind of read cuz with but a
Scientologist won't admit that ever no
that's dumb though because we like just
plain it's obvious obvious I mean anyone
can like if you read Crowley's writings
and you read L ron Hubbard's writings is
like so much
that have already ripped off from there
yeah and they're in their worse actually
connections between them I mean yeah l
ron hubbard before he made scientology
was hanging out with a bunch of people
that were into this [ __ ] yeah you know a
damn Satanist magician [ __ ] rocket
scientists down in BAM LA blowing
themselves up and just swapping wives
and stuff yeah LRH was Jack Parsons
nobody asked us to do a show about a zoo
that's like [ __ ] I should have thrown
him on this show but it is a crew is
just proved just because you're a rocket
scientist doesn't mean you're not a
sorcerer you can be both things Yeah
right you could believe in some crazy
[ __ ] well yeah some people do it's like
just because you're smart in one thing
doesn't mean you're smart in everything
Who am I to say believe in crazy [ __ ] I
mean I [ __ ] saw poltergeist true you
know modern all [ __ ] on magic but if
magic works just because you psyched
yourself up into it I think then all of
a sudden
yes ionic abilities happen I think it
wouldn't work if you believe that it
will work yeah to an extent I mean
obviously there's some stuff that I rise
but possible but that's not the product
that those guys were selling to [ __ ]
rubes though yeah you had I mean they
were selling something that they needed
to make money with yeah like astrology
or something yeah so as I mentioned
curly actually ended up purchasing
Alaskan house from the Frazer family in
1899 now at that time the house was
actually called the manner of Valeska
and ebert ARF because that was the name
of the local parish that it was in now
Crowley had bought this house because he
thought it was the ideal place to
sequester himself away where he was
going to perform a series of operations
known as the sacred magic of a bur melon
the mage he got this from a grimoire
called the book of Abra melon now this
book actually the story in it it's about
an Egyptian mage named Abraham or Abram
melon and he teaches a system of magic
to his acolyte who on another guy named
Abraham Abraham of worms in Germany this
guy was supposedly a real guy he
live from 1362 - 1458 now this book it's
a it's a real book it originally was 12
manuscripts and one printed edition the
earliest manuscripts are two versions
from 1608 the first printed version was
in German and dates from 1725 so
currently was apparently very interested
in this book in this text and he wanted
to do this particular ritual that was in
this grimoire now he had been searching
for a house with the qualities that
bolas can possessed I saw a documentary
about it and like a friend of his or
someone that you know knew a lot about
him or something like that was saying
that he had been looking for this
property for about a year now he says in
his book the confessions of Aleister
Crowley that the first thing you needed
to do this ritual was a house in a more
or less secluded situation he wanted a
door opening to the north from the room
where the Oratory was like where you
were gonna do the ritual outside the
door there had to be room to construct a
terrace that was covered with river sand
and the terrace had to end with like a
building that was like a lodge and
that's where the spirits were supposed
to congregate like in this building so
when he found when he found Valeska
dress it was kind of like seemed perfect
for his needs because it was kind of
like far away from everybody else it had
North facing doors and whatnot so he
actually moves into the house kind of
sets aside the southwestern half of the
house for the ritual and he put the
terrace in and the lodge in and like I
said you can still see it's kind of all
sand in the front even from back in the
day and then then he set up his oratory
with you know these big mirrors and all
this other kind of stuff now this house
he considered it what they would call a
Philemon Qibla which I saw this one
thing that called it sort of like a
Mecca like for esotericism
a focal point for mystical energy and I
think even nowadays people that are
still acolytes of curly I think they
even like the way that you know people
would like bow towards Mecca or whatever
that they'll bow toward bol eScan you
know it means in that direction so this
was supposed to be not just a house but
like kind of like a a Center for like
spiritual energy I guess now when he got
the house all set up he starts the
ritual like I said this is a complicated
ritual is supposed to take like six
months or something like that and you
had to do like all this [ __ ] beforehand
like you so it takes six months yeah I
think so
like it's like yeah it's like this big
long [ __ ] thing and like even before
that you had to like be celibate yeah
just like no alcohol you had like dude
like fasting and all this other kind of
stuff like before okay so all right kind
of making a little more sense oh they
just think about it yeah the magic that
he's talking about is not you do this
and this and you'll get what you want
yes I'm unknown mechanism he's saying
you have to do this long process
yeah that's tedious yeah well what's
gonna happen it's just gonna happen is
it's gonna be kind of like a situation
like meditation yeah or very intense
extended prayer that is gonna put you
into an altered state of awareness
because you're concentrating and
focusing or relaxing or something to
allowing something to happen through
faith yeah this is a faith thing not so
much what you're doing it's the task
yeah the length of the task to get thee
to get the results that you want which
okay what's like I said I if magic works
it's because of that yeah okay it's
because of the mindset you've been put
into an altered state of consciousness
and that's what I that's what I meant
when I said that I think that he
actually was a true believer in this
stuff because it's like why would you
subject yourself to something this
tedious something this difficult that
takes so long you know what I mean and
like I said we went to a Tibetan monks
sitting there yeah all for [ __ ] 30
days yeah it's essentially the same
thing yeah and you know what it reminds
me of it I don't know if I've
recommended this movie but there was a
[ __ ]
movie that came out in 2016 2017
something like that called a dark song
it's a British horror movie and it's
actually a similar kind of thing it's
like this woman that goes to this
magician it's set in the modern day but
because she wants to bring her son back
from the dead I believe so she goes to
this magician and he basically says that
he locks her there locked up in this
house for like six months or a year or
whatever and they're doing this type of
ritual where it's just like every day
they have to get up and she has to like
you know she does all kind of like food
purges and fasting and like she has to
sit in one place you know with without
moving for like hours and hours of time
so it's like this big long yeah it's
like taxing on the mind and yeah
extended periods of like suffering and a
certain types of emotional emotional
arousal that's bringing this about you
know I mean it's basically it's
mind-altering yeah because it's like
bringing you out of yourself some people
have said that mind-altering drugs can
bring about paranormal phenomenon you
know yeah for instance who's the kind of
does a big podcast he talked about
ayahuasca all the time huge oh rogon Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan yeah he talks about that
ayahuasca yeah and that bring you know
that you're talking to alien [ __ ]
souls and stuff you know it sounds very
interesting I mean I'm sure it's cool
and it's like I'd be intrigued to try it
the only the only thing that I wouldn't
want is like I've heard that it makes
you feel like [ __ ] on toast oh yeah they
are six through the whole thing yeah
which that does not sound like a fun
I've got to go somewhere to the Yucatan
to get that you know with some tribal
okay I mean even even other
hallucinogenic drugs that make you feel
shitty the next day it's like that is
bad but it's like not as bad as I've
heard think joe says you feel shitty at
the time see that just shouldn't sound
like a good time say nothing you get
these a really bad diarrhea you vomit
I've heard that he's sick and then then
evidently that goes away and then you
have like this extended period where
you're like getting messages from an
alternate dimension yeah and he says it
checked out
okay that's he says all the stuff that
he was told checked out I mean I guess
why you'd want to do it but and then
when you do it again
evidently the same Souls you spoke to
welcome you back as if they were waiting
for you and it's okay that's [ __ ]
weird yeah you know I don't know anybody
they can get it here yeah I've never I
don't know anyone that see illegal
well obviously down in the Yucatan on
those reservations it's not yeah we're
going down there to go do to go do it
yeah because it's not I say it's not
recreational you know their identity
that if you were like really wanted like
an enlightening you know for your walk
through the spirit world
which I get that I get that um but yeah
just I I don't know if I'd want to do it
bad enough to like have to go through
like all the vomiting and pooping and
wanna well you know me I got no problem
vomiting yeah she would do that [ __ ] the
funny thing about him and vomiting is
that he's very very like calm about I
talk when I'm vomiting yeah he'll just
and he can like hold he'll just be like
um yeah I think I have to throw up yeah
and then he'll just like go to blame and
I'll throw up and then he'll come back
yeah I don't get upset about it I do I
try not to like as hard as I can but
sometimes throwing up since I was a kid
I gotta meet you but I hate it I try I
try to avoid usually I have to throw up
it feels good throwing up yeah to me you
know man that's true the [ __ ] Romans
did it all the time they go to the
free-throw cuz they just wanted to eat
some more c'mon they're late bulimics no
yeah that's a good idea that's that's a
[ __ ] sign that's a sign of [ __ ]
tremendous [ __ ] opulence and wealth
yeah you have so much food that you
can't even eat it on candid it also what
you do is you eat and go Manish it was
good they're gonna throw to suddenly
talk I'm not done with the deliciousness
yeah that's right talk about wagon you
dig
then they'd have a [ __ ] slave do it
some blonde blue hair dyed German girls
lipstick it [ __ ] feather down your
throat see you can throw up and you'd be
talking front talking nice to everybody
why you thought up and then go back out
there but you see the Romans are weird
you know they'd has a communal toilet
there sit on a toilet in [ __ ] crap
and talking to each other see that's
that's crazy to me because a social
event [ __ ] you know I love talking
about it conversations on the can yeah
with the ancient Rome we got somebody
else scrubbing your ass this is the life
yeah yeah the stands were different back
then
actually it wasn't a corn cob it was a
bunch of cotton I said have a stick mid
wash it yes they wash it from one person
to the next
yeah ain't that some [ __ ] yeah so all
right so the ritual that Crowley was
gonna perform like I said it was a
six-month-long
ritual now I think the press at the time
and the press even to the present day I
think they kind of um they make it sound
like he just like went into this house
for this ritual he was gonna summon
demons that's not entirely correct what
he was actually doing and you what he
did like even before he began the ritual
he did like this kind of invocation
example his Diaries from the time and
everything like that cuz he was like
keeping track of what he was doing um
you know he says in there like in the
invocation and his diary before he
started the ritual that he made a
promise not to offend the God and not to
quote unquote work ill against his
neighbors so he wasn't like trying to do
anything bad or anything so what he was
trying to do was he was trying to evoke
the Lords of Darkness which sounds bad
it sounds like demons but what he was
trying to do by invoking them was he was
trying to get them to serve the good so
he was essentially invoking demons in
order to like turn them to the
outside or get them to do good instead
of yeah that's what the Aztecs did right
so it's like so it's not necessarily
like oh I'm gonna summon a bunch of
demons and like rain hell down on it but
that's what wasn't what he what his
intention was so he was hoping that by
the end of this ritual he would summon
they call it a guardian angel but it's
more like a higher like an enlightened
version of yourself kind of yeah yeah
what do they call de Mon yeah
essentially and that this being would
kind of lead him to enlightenment
now the ritual is supposed to be very
dangerous because obviously when you're
summoning evil forces or demons or
whatever and you're trying to turn them
toward the good clearly they don't
really want to do that and are probably
gonna put up a fight and you're gonna
have like all these kind of problems and
stuff like that which is why this was a
very taxing very exacting ritual you
know that you had to have like a lot of
preparation and honey you knew listeners
I believe in the Dame on [ __ ] concept
because you know I had a near-death
experience with a motorcycle when I was
in the army right right before I was
realistic so I was in a coma for a
couple weeks you know and had this
near-death experience went to heaven
with the life review and you know the
title heaven life review seeing some
weird kind of spiritual ancestors people
that knew you and they would knew you
from throughout time you know and there
was a higher being there that spoke to
me that wasn't God but it was a
different version of me it was like a
super me it went throughout time as the
day moms exactly where they're taught my
that's what I saw
so I think that's what he's talking
about when he says guardian angel I
think you mean like super me like you
said right it's like super me but you're
just from one lifetime and the super me
is from with all lifetimes the outside
the space-time continuum yeah yeah it's
not like the ultimate you that's weird
but so I guess people had that
experience came back from it and and
recorded it in that idea what
became a meme I guess yeah in occult
writings but that's one of the things
that you can feel when you have a
near-death experience I'm not the only
one that felt that yeah some people
don't feel that or don't have that
experience but other ones do yeah cuz
someone's like kind of um near-death
experiences are kind of all over the map
just liar it's like you're playing a
video game okay and you're looking at
the little character on the screen and
then all of a sudden you realize you're
that character at the screen and it
turns around and looks at you through
the screen and you yeah who's that it's
like you're just the avatar but like
you're as well I was like it looks like
where you see the player yeah and you
know I'm an Indian that that's the
relationship yeah that's actually
probably a good way of putting it but
yeah I think that that's what curly was
that was like the ultimate goal of this
ritual he was doing yeah now apparently
like I said this ritual was taken you
know six months so it's like kind of a
lot of [ __ ] that he's going through
every day now in his diary he started
recording like all this weird [ __ ] that
started happening around the house while
the ritual was in progress he said in
his diary one day I came back from
shooting rabbits on the hill and found a
Catholic priest in my study I hate when
that happens
call the exterminator he had come to
tell me that my lodge-keeper a total
abstainer
for 20 years had been raving drunk for
three days and had tried to kill his
wife and children hmm so uh yeah so
apparently like all this crazy [ __ ]
started going around going on while he
was doing the ritual presumably because
he was conjuring up demons even though
he supposedly had good intentions for
doing it but I guess it's like never
good to like conjure demons up because
he also said that he had hired this guy
to do labor around the grounds of the
house that guy also apparently went nuts
and tried to kill him try to kill
Aleister Crowley he also had another
lodge-keeper I don't think this is the
same one that got drunk and tried to
kill his wife and kid but he had a lodge
keeper named Hugh gillies who had a
whole bunch of like terrible [ __ ] happen
to him like two of his kids died and all
this other
stuff like that should happen so now
problem was what what you're supposed to
do when you do this ritual you're
supposed to do it until it's done and
you're not supposed to like leave in the
middle you're not supposed to like be
interrupted or anything like that
however while he was doing the ritual he
gets a message from Samuel Liddell
McGregor mathur Mathers who at the time
was the leader of the Golden Dawn and
Aleister Crowley's master now Mathers
was in Paris mmm and it evidently gotten
himself into a little bit of trouble
what was going on was that the members
of the Golden Dawn were kind of getting
pissed off with Mathers leadership and
also like his kind of close relationship
with Crowley because I guess some of
them didn't like Curley so they were
just like this big like conflict they're
also I feel like the the adepts you know
the people that were in the Golden Dawn
they were like they didn't like that
Mathers was kind of like he was that he
said that he was the only one that could
contact the secret Chiefs you know like
the entities that were supposedly had
all the knowledge and everything so the
the people that were in the Golden Dawn
said you know we don't really need him
to do that he seems like kind of you
know autocratic we want to contact them
ourselves like we don't want him to be a
middleman so there was like kind of this
conflict it was a lot of them were
leaving and like wanted to form their
own temples and stuff like that
so Mathers was kind of like getting
upset it was like everything was getting
chaotic so he sends a message to Crowley
because Crowley had once told him
apparently that it's like you know hey
if you ever need me or if you ever need
my money or anything like that just call
me and I'll be there to help you so
Mathers you know calls them up not I'm
not on the phone and obviously but it's
like sends him a letter and it's like
hey remember that time when you said
that if I ever needed help or need the
money or anything well now is that time
so you got to come help me out
now even though Crowley knew the
it was very dangerous to leave the
ritual unfinished he figured well I have
to go help Mathers out he even wrote at
the time in his diary he wrote as far as
I was concerned Mathers was my only link
with the secret Chiefs to whom I was
pledged I wrote to him offering to place
myself and my fortune unreservedly at
his disposal if that meant giving up the
abra Mellon operation for the present
alright so he basically like he makes
this big deal about this book and ritual
and then he's just like well I got a
stop in the middle like you know because
my friend needed my help and everything
like that where are we on time um we're
actually in an hour so I think we're
gonna take a break right now can we come
back we'll talk yeah we'll talk a little
bit more about Aleister Crowley we'll
talk a little bit about stuff that
happened at burlesque in house
subsequently like after he moved out
we'll talk a little bit about Jimmy Page
and his purchase of the house and stuff
like that so we'll be back in just a few
minutes yeah can mommy please have the
camera have it no I can't have it you're
gonna have it
oh it's Pookie camera that's right Oh
Pookie
look at this yeah oh now she's gonna
lick her butt okay you're so classy so
classy yeah yeah what you're doing what
do you have to say about that
but yeah get in there get in there okay
bye
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
and we're back talking about moleska
house and Aleister Crowley we forgot to
mention when we were doing the shout
outs that we sent out the shirts for $20
note patrons that got to me about side
and got back to me about sizes and stuff
this is what the shirt looks like yeah
wait here
boobs not included there you go - up to
13 o'clock and Friday 31 yeah so we
chose the hour of the weird &
unexplained yeah in the frame 13 yeah
you want one of the posters
so um sure it's $20 yeah shipping inside
the continental United States is about
five dollars so 25 for a shirt yeah um
shipping to UK expensive what was that
15 bucks
somewhere 15 and somewhere 24 okay so if
you want to go out to the UK contact us
directly maybe we can work something out
yeah cuz we could it's quite expensive
yeah we mailed some out like um to the
patrons
right we I don't know why it's like some
of them were cheaper than others like it
seemed like a big like some of them were
for 14.95 and then some of them were $24
even UK's profit profiteering off that
mailman although some but like I said
some of the ones to the UK were only
1495 I don't know if it was a difference
in weight I didn't think there was that
much of a drastic difference in weight
maybe it was just because some of the
packages were bigger than others like
because some of the envelopes I had were
like eight and a half by eleven and some
were like I had something to do with
like Ireland wasn't that expensive when
I went to Ireland yeah no I think that
one was 24 24 yeah okay I think I care I
thought that one was long like we mailed
so many I think it had to do with the
size of the envelopes because some of
the envelopes were smaller yeah and some
of the envelope I think so we were
talking about Aleister Crowley and like
I said he was in the middle of this Abra
Mellon ritual that he was doing and he
gets called to Paris to bail out his
friend Mathers his master you know head
of the Golden Dawn at the time so he
his ritual unwisely and goes to Paris to
help his friend out ironically even
though health ster croelick is the story
goes that the reason that Valeska house
like had so many hauntings and horrible
things about it that supposedly happened
later on was because Crowley left the
ritual undone like in the middle like
yet because you know anybody that's into
like magic or the occult or anything
like that knows that when you summon
demons or spirits or whatnot like in one
of these rituals the last thing you're
supposed to do is like you know get rid
of them it was like you know dispel them
at the end and apparently he didn't do
that so the story grew up around the
house that like it was because he had
left in the middle without without
finishing the ritual that like you know
all of these spirits like still stayed
around the house now like I said
ironically even though you know Crowley
had interrupted this very important
ritual to go to Mathers apparently the
two of them had a falling-out much later
on and in fact in Crowley's novel
moonchild he actually wrote Mathers in
there as a villain and Mathers actually
ended up dying about a year after that I
think it was in 1918 it's weird because
they're not sure how he died
that it was probably because I mean
there was a flu epidemic going out at
the time so he probably died in that but
there's no like cause of death listed on
his death certificate so I thought that
was a little weird
so after Aleister Crowley left for Paris
to help out Mathers people who lived
around the area began to complain that
there were all these like dark clouds
like hanging over Bowl esken house and
that there was like this really creepy
like oppressive feeling and like people
were starting to like avoid it because
there was like like bad [ __ ] going on up
there
now after like kerley helped Mathers out
and he comes back to Belle esken and he
said that as soon as he got back there
that he could feel like changes that it
felt different like when he came back
apparently one of his protegees that had
been at the house like helping him out
what the ritual presumably had left
while he was
on he also said that he started he's
like that the house was like unnaturally
dark he's like even when the day outside
was really sunny like when he was in his
study which had like big windows and was
like a really sunny like brightly lit
room he was in there like writing down
stuff for the rituals and everything
like that and he's like it was so dark
in there that he needed like artificial
light to see because for some reason
like it was like there was a kind of
pall of darkness like around the house
and like the Sun couldn't reach in or
something like that is what he was
saying he also said that he started
seeing like shadowy shapes like outside
like on the lodge and like the terrace
which is where the spirits were supposed
to congregate and everything he said he
would like see them out of the corner of
his eye and he said in his diary that it
was like really hard to explain them
he's like they weren't really shapes but
they were like almost like your vision
he said your vision suffering some
interference that sounds like that's as
if the as if they weren't even objects
that he's that sounds like that thing
that I saw him at mom yeah it's it did
sound like that when he described it he
said blue haze and clear balls yeah I
couldn't really focus on but he said
this these were almost opaque but he
said that they weren't he says this is a
quote from his diary it says It was as
if they belonged to an order of matter
which affected the site without
informing it that's exactly that's
exactly what that's what he said that's
exactly what I've tried to describe to
you yeah that's weird okay all right
yeah he said he started seeing that kind
of stuff like around around the house
yeah like I said there was a press of
atmosphere that was like it seemed like
dark all the time like they couldn't get
the sunlight to come in apparently there
was like just this really really strong
winds like gale force winds that would
blow through the rooms even though the
weather was nice outside people would
see like weird figures like shadowy
figures like out of the corner of my eye
of their eyes and stuff like that was
weird
he also I'm not down
I'd have to say for myself yeah but he's
describing is familiar to me so yeah
okay whether or not they manifested that
themselves using you know I mean their
own mind or if it was something from
another dimension coming in you know
there's no way to know what I guess yeah
I tend to think well okay I'm just gonna
leave it up to em I wasn't there
well like I said this was a very long
time ago it's like you know what I mean
here
he also wrote in his diary and this is a
you know this is a direct quote from his
diary he says on my return to Bell Eskin
I started to prepare once more for the
great operation so he was gonna like
restart the ritual don't know if he was
starting over from the beginning or if
you can like come back where he left off
I don't know how that works
suddenly I knew that a rival magician
was attacking me now in the diary he
said that it was a magician he knew he
oh I named him before but I don't know
who it wasn't he was talking about at
this time I kept a pack of bloodhounds
and he succeeded this the rival magician
he succeeded in killing them off one
after another there was absolutely no
sign of any sort of disease they simply
died
the servants too were continually
becoming ill one with this complaint one
with the other
action was necessary one morning we
heard screams and oaths from the
direction of the kitchen one of the
workmen had become suddenly maniacal and
attacked my wife whose name was rose
that's who he was married to at the time
who was making her usual morning
inspection we overpowered him and shut
him in the coal cellar until the police
arrived so apparently people were
getting weird illnesses the dogs were
dying off people were starting to act
crazy pants and they're putting it down
to him not you know ending the ritual
properly and like messing it up and like
leaving in the middle there's another
story that went around about this time
period this was was about a local
butcher who came to the house to get the
meat order I guess he came there like
every so often so he comes to get the
meat order while the ritual was going on
and he apparently kept ringing the
doorbell because I guess he was like I
know some of
goddammit so he kept like ringing the
doorbell curly got really mad because he
was like messing up his concentration so
he picks up a piece of paper really
quickly he writes the meat order on it
and then gives it to the boots like
sticks it under the door like it is a
bush it's like ok here just go away now
apparently the paper that he brooded on
had a spell written on it and shortly
afterwards the butcher was cutting up
the meat for Crowley's order back at the
butcher shop and apparently cut all his
fingers off his right hand with the
cleaver so that's a I've also heard that
he cut his whole hand off I'm not really
sure what said what part of that is true
but apparently it's just because Crowley
was so pissed off and he didn't I don't
think he meant to like write the meat
order on the spell it's just he grabbed
the first piece of paper cuz he's like
god damn that [ __ ] won't stop
ringing the doorbell so apparently the
the spell like made the butcher collect
cut all his fingers off that's kind of
that's the kind of tail that curly would
tell yeah he did that shot gosh it
constantly yeah but uh yeah you know I
appreciate his imagination though yeah
that's what like I said that's a good
story as part of his PR yeah yeah yeah
he kind of liked like I said even though
I don't really think that he had any
intention to do anyone any harm I think
that he thought he seemed to find it
amusing that other people thought that
he was like this really horrible like
evil and he encouraged that I feel like
little stories like that you know and I
mean also yeah l ron Hubbard mm-hmm had
a bunch of stories about that well this
happened and you know Walker they didn't
listen when I said you know his mouth
and [ __ ] they didn't listen what I said
and you don't hang this what that's what
happened to them yeah yeah a lot of
these sorcerers but can have little Pete
little stories like well I mean if
you're gonna go into sorcery like as a
career that's right path you have to
have some stories you got to have some
stories like that to kind of build up
your rep wrong know what I mean because
if your sorcerers are nothing without
their arrived even haven't even Elvis
had those stories yeah well wasn't even
a sorcerer yeah well except in
Mississippi Mississippi he was
definitely he was
is a messiah yeah he could stop it from
rainin yeah Wow was it was that while he
was driving while he was driving working
at that I think he was in the back of
his car in his convertible uh in his
convertible Cadillac yeah I started
raining a little bit and he said no it
needs to stop raining and it stopped
then everyone went to Memphis lob the
Memphis [ __ ] remember dad oh
[ __ ] yeah
that's probably how that [ __ ] get
started it's like something totally
mundane it's like and then just you
could stop him from raining
well that one time I mean when I was a
kid when I was a kid is that sippy
[ __ ] other kids that I knew in
Mississippi their parents told them that
Elvis had the power to stop make it stop
raining because that was the stories
that they told yeah that's like the only
magical power he had though he couldn't
like heal the sick or anything um trying
to think did he have like any other kind
of Jesus powers well you don't need the
Cana you don't need Jesus powers when
you have Jesus status trail you know I'm
talking about I'm just saying like of
all the super powers it's like hey I can
make it stop rain and everybody's like
Whoopi do from right now that's all I
can remember okay it's just that make it
stop you can stop before right yeah
there might be some more you know I'm
sure you can look it up and I'm sure you
can google like lightning enemies no but
he probably healed some children yeah I
feel like healing that was kind of like
I'm sure there's some stories in that's
you're pretty like pedestrian like he
goes to a hospital with kids with
terminal cancer and then they were all
they were all hearing I'm sure there's
stories like that out there
I bet there is my google that is saying
it was basically a story that he
survived death true I mean you know the
Elvis sightings are basically them
saying now he didn't die yeah he's still
yeah he's still alive
yeah so there were some other stories
too apparently one of Crowley's
housekeepers disappeared mysteriously
also another local workman
went crazy you know so like I said
there's a lot of a lot of people that
like work at this house and stuff
like that and they're kind of like going
mental and stuff now apparently he
didn't finish the ritual this time
either I'm not entirely sure why but
after he came back from his Paris
sojourn and kind of got a little bit
into trying to restart the ritual I'm
like apparently all these horrible
things were happening like with the
butcher presumably and like all these
people going crazy and like them seeing
all this crazy [ __ ] so he actually
stopped spending most of his time at the
house so not long after that he actually
went to New York and then he went to
Egypt now in Egypt he did the ritual
again they're like - supposedly - like
contact his you know guardian angel or
whatever now he said that that time it
was successful but at that point it
seems like he wasn't really into Valeska
anymore
and he actually ended up leaving the
property for good in 1913 he moved to a
cottage elsewhere and as I mentioned
earlier practitioners of Thelema are
still instructed to turn and face north
tubal eScan when they're doing certain
magical ceremonies now after Crowley
left the house it's not empty for for a
little bit but then now interestingly
the Wikipedia page says that an American
actor named George Raft bought the house
after World War one this is not correct
George Raft was actually he was a real
actor he was an American actor he played
a lot of gangsters and stuff like that
but the actor that actually bought
Alaskan house was actually named George
Sanders he was an English actor kind of
known for playing a lot of CAD sort of
characters like rogue sort of characters
he even wrote an autobiography called
the memoirs of a professional CAD he
actually wasn't English sorry he was
Russian but he moved to England in 1917
now he apparently he became an actor in
the 1930s he was in like a [ __ ] ton of
movies but most people would probably
recognize him from All About Eve he
played Addison DeWitt
he was also married to
Zsa Zsa Gabor for a time and later
married the older sister Magda Gabor so
he was married to two separately not at
the same time the Gabor is all looked
alike thank you they were cute yeah
they're really cute yeah they did how
many of them are there
bacha I don't even watch them and they
they were like the Baldwin's then yeah
they stormed Hollywood they got shows
and [ __ ] you know I remember Jean Jean
and a couple of the other ones like
being on [ __ ] Dharma I remember I got
fat old yeah [ __ ] drink out of a
flask and get [ __ ] loaded in
Hollywood and like slap cops that pulled
her over yeah that was that was a big
story
you never slapping the cops slapping the
cop how dare you pull me over
she was like what was she a countess I
don't remember I think she was kind of
[ __ ] Romanian or Hungarian I think
she was Hungarian no no bill these
little people like yeah and she slap a
cop man [ __ ] Sabbath it didn't work
yeah it doesn't really matter who you
are now
probably don't want to work for tip but
she got street cred Fetchit yeah you
don't pull over Xiao Xiao I'm sha sha
pow I'm Sasha if I pulled that [ __ ]
they'd probably just shoot me in the
face yeah lucky lucky that the cop knew
exactly who she was yeah he probably
just thought it was funny they locked
her ass up I think she bought out yeah
kind of yeah so so yeah so George
Sanders uh owned it for a while that
we'll get back to him in a minute but I
wanted to talk about a little bit about
because Bowl eScan is on Loch Ness you
know there has to be a little bit of a
Loch Ness monster connection
it was Princess Zsa Zsa wasn't she a
princess uh or maybe she just called
herself princess yeah oh yeah cuz
anybody can do yeah right yeah I'm not
sure check with my mom about that she
would know that was that generation yeah
like I remember her I remember her being
on was she on like Hollywood Squares or
something yeah
she did that like a game show did
Hollywood Squares she had her a couple
of sitcoms she was at Green Acres she
married a bunch of like famous guys and
yeah and rapid secession yeah famous
Hollywood guys she was calm professor
she was kind of like a professional
girlfriend or a professional life I
guess you could say yeah she was just
marry a famous guy get the fame yes
diamonds yeah get the [ __ ] out yeah and
she's like I think she was known for
that going all the way back to the 60s
yeah yeah she was cute though yeah yeah
she's good and like I said there was a
bunch of those go bores I can t get sha
Shan Ava and Oh Magda there was mad yeah
maybe it was just three I don't know I
don't know I feel like there was more of
them than that like you know look about
the same like the Baldwin's there's like
blondes yeah so um so like I said in the
1930s when the sightings of the Loch
Ness monster first started taking place
they actually asked cruelly about the
Loch Ness monster because he lived on
the Loch obviously um and he kind of
wrote this big long piece that was
published in a newspaper over there it's
called the Empire News Now I don't think
he had ever seen it but he was talking
about how interested he was and
everything like that now interestingly
though there was this one guy named
Frederick William Holliday and he is
kind of a Loch Ness monster guy
cryptozoologist type of dude and he
published a couple of books about the
Loch Ness monster and in the 1970s he
seemed to come to the conclusion that
because some people had described the
Loch Ness monster as having some aspects
of a supernatural creature he began to
speculate that maybe the Loch Ness
monster had been summoned by Aleister
Crowley in this ritual that he'd like
maybe the Loch Ness monster was one of
the demons that he brought up well
there's no evidence for Loch Ness
monster no there's no food for it
ness monster so therefore the Loch Ness
monster must have been summoned it's a
supernatural being we'll see and that
would explain it this is the same as
saying that Bigfoot's made yes for
spiritual Bigfoot yeah I guarantee you
all this [ __ ] extra dimensional
Bigfoot it's all [ __ ] that's just
because the kids are evidence there's no
evidence there's no footprints but I'm
not saying that there is no [ __ ]
Bigfoot yeah I've heard some compelling
stories about Bigfoot like I said I bet
you're talking about up in Washington
State in Canada where [ __ ] people
haven't [ __ ] big you where there had
been very few people in the fest 15,000
years you know I mean yeah maybe but no
no no you would think with all the
infrared technology and spy satellites
that they can probably see every inch of
the earth and every living creature on
the earth and you would think NSA or one
of the spy [ __ ] satellites would have
seen something like a humanoid out in in
the forest and Washington State yeah
it's like I'm not like I said of all the
you know cryptids or paranormal stuff or
whatever obviously the you know Bigfoot
is like the least crazy I mean his eye
he would just be a big ape or like a man
like oh my god you've got to so I'm not
saying that there is that there is there
isn't what I'm saying
I think oring pendick is more likely
then than yeah but yeah but I'm not
saying it's impossible yeah I don't
think it's impossible either because
like I said you know it's a creature if
you live down list I mean there's lots
of creatures that they you know that
they're only just finding now that's
like if it lit up some remote area I'd
love to see one as far as the Loch Ness
monster though I don't know because man
there's like there's a road right around
there there's like people live there and
[ __ ] like that and I just feel like I
there's just there's a big problem it's
a big lake but there's a big problem for
there to be a breeding population it has
to be a breeding population of them all
right and in order for them to be a
breeding population has to be a lot of
food for them to eat there's no food in
Loch Ness since it's cold as [ __ ] it's
cold as [ __ ] there's nothing crawling
really on the bottom things mean you can
sit it's muddy and murky down there in
certain areas but you can stave set [ __ ]
submersible cameras to show you that
their bottoms barren yeah there isn't
much of an ecosystem in Loch Ness it's
cold you know and if there were a
breeding population of these damn
[ __ ] dinosaurs they'd be up on the
surface [ __ ] taking Sun and splashing
around screwing each other in public
[ __ ] like they do cuz they're just
animals in Loch Ness monster [ __ ]
yeah just animals they wouldn't be shy
well why would they be shy
yeah especially if they were that size
yeah there's elephants that I don't know
yeah they're laying up on a surface like
I'll just sit on you yeah they wouldn't
have any other natural enemies yeah but
you'd need a large amount you'd need a
large biomass to feed them yeah you know
it's not there yeah I don't think and
there's only one that had been dead and
if there was only two or three they'd be
inbred and they died out it wouldn't
matter you need like 50 of those [ __ ]
at least yeah well you know and you
couldn't hide that so but like I said
you gotta use reason and logic if
Alistair Curley did indeed some enhancer
yeah abra melon ritual then that would
explain it because it's a supernatural
being and therefore does not need to eat
or mate so there's just one of them he's
just whooshing around in the Rotter and
he's like a demon or something don't
come up with anything man just because
he happened to live there and there was
that legend about oh he didn't finish
the ritual I'm like I use a baton around
you know I used to sit back and
fantasize that maybe there was a log no
moss it would be cold there was but
because some of the programs were so
awesome there was nothing first thing is
so yeah creepy yet I mean yeah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] down in there yeah but it
doesn't make any sense from a logical
standpoint
yeah and I understand how biology works
I mean if it would be different if they
said o Loch Ness monster he's in like
the Pacific Ocean yeah right it's like I
could buy that
right but not in that little leg but in
that one little lake no I don't think so
I don't think so now and what's funny is
that there are stories that are equally
as cool that we know are true based on
the dam drawings and wood cuts from the
Middle Ages yeah and Whitman and knowing
how fish are
there were times in the Middle Ages
where some of those Lakes had catfish so
I can figure that's a [ __ ] huge yeah
huge [ __ ] catfish type varieties you
know where they were the size of cows
yeah people thought that those wood cuts
all it couldn't be own oh hell yeah they
got that big because they didn't have
fishing block and they didn't have
fishing technology back then the only
way to sew a fish would grow to immense
size you know I mean I don't know how
long someone's fish gonna live yeah a
hundred of catfish get [ __ ] huge okay
well how big did they get when they're
150 years old if you're not catching
with rod and reel cuz he didn't have
that back then yeah a fish could grow to
150 years of age yeah the only way you
could catch it was by draining the lake
or running a big old dragnet through it
that's usually how they got it good they
was showing some of the wood cuts of a
damn cow next to a catfish and they were
the same size and they were like wait a
minute no can't be and but what's his
name the guy who's uh Jeremy Wade that's
a nice way to sleep that my liver
monsters yeah well he's caught some
catfish almost that bubbles that size so
you know the thought that there's some
like a little bit bigger than that
that's not crazy to think about having
that much bigger yes some of the [ __ ]
catfish is kind there were like
horrifying yeah you know that catfish
can get as big as a shark yeah basically
and like David said like [ __ ]
babbling man like it's sweet yeah they
were big enough to swallow a person ever
and there were there were medieval
stories of fish in lakes swallowing
people and then people were like that
didn't happen
that's medieval [ __ ] making that [ __ ]
up oh hell no they're talking about a
damn catfish yeah okay when you think
about it it is kind of that would be
like an aside any way to go fish catfish
and Mississippi and [ __ ] you know
grab cat fish out of the water noodle
and then I'm gonna [ __ ] like that I'm
just lucky that there wasn't some
monster out there cuz there's a lot of
guys out there doing it you know for
generations before me you know yeah they
got all of their guys so they kind of
cold to the big ones yeah well you know
what a catfish couldn't live that long
yeah because people were fishing them we
had the technology to the fishermen but
in the Middle Ages they didn't yeah they
didn't have rod and reel so they just
got bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger
and you'd be like you know in the little
river washing out your pantaloons or
whatever and all of a sudden no [ __ ]
catfish comes up in that's all she wrote
you wouldn't even know what happened to
you now you know I knew people who had
relatives and knew people in Louisiana
and they would talk about that the
[ __ ] most deadliest thing was an
alligator guard I just kind of laugh at
him though officially the older people
because a guard didn't get that big but
then I found out that now back in the
20s and 30s for death they were they had
damn paddleboats that would go out there
and just electrocute guard on mass yeah
they're trying to wipe them out because
gar got big they got the size an
alligator yeah you know that
theoretically a car buy get meat might
get to be 12 feet long and there are
things that are like that yeah they're
like arapaima type stuff you're not I
mean Bo and Jeremy Wade's got some
really big pine material right that
shows Gary I caught some big gar but
they were like maybe five and a half six
feet long I've seen five and a half six
via but those are evidently the babies
yeah yeah I mean everything I've never
seen more can live to be 50 60 years old
and you're talking about like 12 13 feet
you know but they don't live that long
anymore yeah you know people fish him
but yeah I think well I used to swim it
like a whole bunch of different Springs
and stuff but I used to see yeah I used
to see those gars but I don't think like
he said I think the biggest one I ever
saw was maybe people people in other
countries don't know what a gar is it's
a primitive fish that has a head with a
big long snout fill with sharp teeth
they're like needle teeth yeah it looks
like an alligator head it's a
prehistoric looking fish with gigantic
scales on it yeah and a bunch of fins
almost kind of like like an eel yeah
kind of like a weird-ass heel but it's
not it's a primitive fish yeah and in my
day they didn't get that big six feet
yeah which is this a big fish yeah it's
scary and a half of the head yeah but
you know evidently older people you know
like my grandparents generation where
they were talking about 12 13 14 and
rumors of like 20 foot long gar big
enough to kill a man yeah I really
believe it but
it's not that crazy well they had some
pictures of some [ __ ] from the 20s that
yeah is approaching that size and like I
said even just watching River Monsters
yeah and like even the [ __ ] that he
catches nowadays is terrifying enough
and you could imagine that like when you
know there wasn't the overfishing
problem and [ __ ] like that
yeah and you know that the fish could
have gotten a lot bigger than that well
it's not that it was overfishing is if
the population of Louisiana was very low
back then yeah and when people were kind
of colonized in the areas coming into
the modern era they thought those things
were a threat so they actually had these
barges that would go out there and just
try to wipe them out yeah so a lot of
the gar that around they are young for
all we know this huge car that they were
killin might have been over a hundred
years old probably because like I said
they don't know how long they live yeah
so alright so let's go back to talking
about Valeska house now in 1962
Valeska house gets bought by the sky
named Dennis Loraine
now during his time in the house there
was this scam which was called the great
sausage scandal now the actor George
Sanders was also evidently involved in
this somehow so apparently I'm not sure
entirely like sources differ about when
exactly this happened it was either
sometime in the 50s or the 60s some time
around there so Dennis Lorraine was
supposedly gonna set up a company called
Loch Ness foods and say that he was
raising pigs at the house like that he
was using it as a pig farm but he didn't
really have a pig farm I'm not really
sure like what the end game of this was
but it's like you know oh I'll say I
have a pig farm but I don't have a pig
farm that was kind of like the scam so
he ends up getting the actor George
Sanders like involved in this like I
guess to use bull esken house like for
the pig farm you know and then there was
this whole thing so now apparently what
had happened
Dennis Lorraine supposedly bought
Valeska house because his wife whose
name was Molly she
had seen a portrait of a woman named
Mary Lorraine in an art gallery in
Inverness
now Mary Lorraine who the painting was
of she had been the wife of a previous
owner of Bowl eScan who was named major
Edward grant now major Edward grant
fatally shot himself in the head in the
house in either 1960 or 1965 I've seen
that he shot himself in the study are
also that he shot himself in the room
that Aleister Crowley used as his
bedroom now this this is creepy they
actually had this woman named Anna
McClaren who was the housekeeper for
maid for major Edward grant and his
family she was 78 years old and she
actually said later on there was an
interview with her in this documentary
that she saw she had had like a
premonition that Grant was going to die
she said she was out picking vegetables
in the garden and that she heard a
gunshot from the house so she runs into
the house to see what it was but there
was nobody in there so then she like was
like okay well whatever I guess I'm just
hearing things and then she forgot about
it however exactly one week later at the
same time of day
grant shot himself in the head hmm
now the creepy thing was she [ __ ]
described this as she was like a little
old lady and she says this is what she
said in the documentary she said she
came up and she's like I went in the
front door there was this little bone at
the front door they had this little dog
named picky wig thank you I know that
was like named picky Wakeman piggie week
I know that's almost sounds like that's
should be cookies names should she look
she looks like a picky wig sounds like
something from [ __ ] the South like
Piggly Wiggly yeah well when I was
watching her on the documentary I
thought that's what she said I'm like
their dog was a Piggly Wiggly but then
when I looked at him I found the quote
Leon that's picky wig and so it happens
it was like a little bone or something
in picki wig had the bone like in his
mouth and she's like oh where'd you get
that from and she took it out his mouth
and threw it like into the yard
not thinking about it so she goes into
the house to look and she sees grant in
the room with his [ __ ] head blown off
oh she that's where the bone came from
yes go and it's like she didn't realize
it at the time she's like dog was trying
to tell her I know and like she ran out
the house and [ __ ] she said to the wife
she called the police and everything
like that she's like you know he shot
himself in the head and then the
detectives came to her and said yeah
that was a piece of his skull they
actually did search the grounds and they
found it so later on they were able to
bury it with the rest of the remains but
it's just like that was so [ __ ]
creepy that's like this is August trying
to tell her she didn't think about it
she just thought it was a bow just like
hey [ __ ] picky wig yeah and then
they're like oh hey that was the dude
skull cuz he blew his [ __ ] head off
him like oh that's horrible so yeah so
apparently um when Dennis and Molly
Lorraine lived in this house later on
they apparently had a lot of problems -
which apparently stemmed from this curse
or whatever the kind of surrounded the
house they both became alcoholics the
pig farm venture which they got into
this is what I didn't think this was
what I thought was weird there was like
the whole thing about there was a
scandal like Oh we'll have a pig farm
except not really like we're not gonna
have any pigs but apparently they did
have pigs because the story goes that
the pigs were all they kept him in this
field like next to the house and when
the pig farm didn't work out for
whatever reason like they just left the
pigs there and the pigs all starved what
you know what I mean so I'm just like
okay there's a ban in the place and a
big star yeah they just like abandon it
now apparently like why didn't let the
pigs out that's what I mean it's like
they could just rearrange the way for
God or something maybe so you know I've
seen a lot of abandoned animals they do
fine and there's somebody that banded a
bunch of goats those goats live for
[ __ ] eight nine years well especially
as eating [ __ ] especially pigs and goats
and stuff like that because they're
omnivores I mean they can eat anything
so [ __ ] man where I lived in Holly Hill
or Daytona there was like wild pigs that
it like escaped from someone's farm
there was like whole generation of the
amount of that generation run around in
the woods and they're not even afraid of
humans they'll still come up and ask for
food yeah it's like hey you got anything
Hey
well you know any port in a storm he
probably got better [ __ ] than whatever
so yeah I was like reading this one blog
that was kind of talking about bless kin
house and the different stories about it
and this person had actually done like a
lot of research on people that had lived
in it later and he said um that he
wasn't actually sure he's like he didn't
know what ended up happening to Mali
Lorraine a kind of lost track of her
however Denis Lorraine apparently moved
to London and was kind of like destitute
you know what I mean he was kind of like
a drunk and he just went crazy and like
slept with a gun under his pillow and
all this other kind of stuff now there's
also a story on Wikipedia that a married
couple moved into the house in the late
60's story goes the wife was blind and
after a month the man walked out leaving
the woman wandering around unable to see
what so it's like so Wikipedia mentioned
that the guy that wrote this blog was
like I don't really know where they got
that story from like the Wikipedia story
was sourced to a book that came out in
2008 by someone with the last name of
wall so I don't know like where they got
that story from hmm like and the thing
is it's like if if you were blind since
birth it's like you wouldn't just wander
around the house going oh no I can't see
I'm totally helpless they can like still
three other things and like hear things
and stuff they have other senses you
know what I mean
so it's not like she would just wander
around go oh no now I'm gonna starve to
death that's just you guys know what
else is here that's dumb no people are
competent of course they aren't they
know where they are and like I said it's
like their other senses compensate so it
was like I'm not really sure like why
where that story came from so in 1969
experimental filmmaker Kenneth Anger
who was very interested in the occult he
actually found out that Bulacan house
was on the market and he rented it for a
couple of months and that's how Jimmy
Page of Led Zeppelin ended up hearing
about it and he bought the house in 1970
now Jimmy Page as well as the other
members of Led Zeppelin but you know
mostly Jimmy Page was very interested in
alistair crowley he collected a lot of
alistair crowley member be
like he'd read all of his books and was
like really interested in his philosophy
and whatnot so the thing about it is
that I feel like when you were talking
earlier about how OLED Zeppelin lived in
this house and like they're like selling
their soul to the devil and stuff like
that Jimmy Page bought the house but he
didn't really live in it um he owned it
from 1970 I think till 1991 but I think
over that whole entire time from what I
could determine I think he really only
stayed there a total of about six weeks
so it was part he didn't live there so
it was part of his Crowley collection
yeah because he collected just like
memorabilia and stuff I remember hearing
all kinds of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] like
that they wrote [ __ ] stairway to
heaven in that them I mean maybe they
did because he did think he did buy it
because he thought it would one he was
like really into curly but he thought
like the vibes and stuff would be cool
for like writing music and stuff they
wrote the whole [ __ ] what is it was
name of that album houses of the Holy
Family album in there and that they
recorded it in there which I don't
believe that's true at all I think that
was recorded at a professional studio
somewhere but yeah because the thing
about it is that when Jimmy Page bought
the house it was kind of in shitty
condition yeah so you couldn't really I
mean you could live in it but it wasn't
like in the best shape let's do so money
they may have a reason to stay there yes
so he was kind of trying to UM you know
he was trying to restore it like bulb
but he wasn't living in it he did
actually and actually I didn't know this
but Jimmy Page later on he actually
owned an occult bookshop in London
called the equinox but yeah part of his
collection that yeah so so Jimmy Page
didn't live there however his friend
Malcolm dent he actually kind of
recruited Malcolm to live in the house
and like look after it you know and so
Malcolm dent ended up living there for
quite a while and like he lived there
with his family
he's also been interviewed extensively
on documentaries about about the house
and stuff like that so Malcolm dent says
that when he moved into the house he
said it had pretty much been abandoned
for a really long time and it was
essentially a wreck he said there had
been a small fire there at some point
some of it had been burned
as parts of the buildings were like
missing or had like fallen down the
outside grounds were like just looked
really shitty now he claimed that he was
he didn't believe in like any kind of
paranormal or supernatural anything but
he said that as soon as he moved into
the house like all kind of weird [ __ ]
started happening now he says that he
had been living there for a couple of
weeks and then he started hearing like
these weird rumbling sounds like from
the hallway like outside his room and
then when he would go to investigate
there was nothing there but then he
would close the bedroom door again and
then it would start again now because he
was curious about this and I guess the
noise like continued so much it was like
really you know regular so he looked
into the history of the house and came
across the story about good old Lord
Lovat and his severed head rolling up
and down the hallway so that's what
thank you so he's presuming that that's
what that was because I mean that story
had been going around for a long time so
he he said that maybe I guess because
like I said Lord Lovat was executed in
London's there like why would his head
be rolling around on the on the Hall of
Louisville Eskin house but apparently
there's a place just right above Alaskan
that's supposed to be like the
geographical center of the Highlands and
it's supposed to have like some kind of
weird magical energy or something so
movie that like sucked his head there or
I don't know
so Malcolm Den also said that he
experienced what he called the most
terrifying that of my life at Valeska
house he says he woke up one night and
he heard what sounded like a wild animal
like snorting scratching like banging
outside the bedroom door now at first he
said it sounded like a dog but then like
as he listened to it he realized it was
like way too big to be a dog so he's
like the sound kept going on and on and
then he just like laid there all night
like
to it and he said he got a really really
bad feeling that whatever was out there
was like some really big like creature
and it was like pure evil he said that
he got that kind of fear he didn't see
it but he said he heard it like all
night cuz he he was too chicken to get
up and open the door and see what it was
but when he opened the door in the
morning obviously there was nothing
there but he like heard it all night and
he said he got like a really bad feeling
of like concentrated evil there was
apparently another friend of his who
stayed at Bull Eskin house who said she
was attacked by something that looked
like a devil there was also some
poltergeist activity chairs like a
furniture with like switch places like
her be in different places doors slammed
open and closed like by themselves rugs
would roll up by themselves and all this
other kind of stuff but however despite
this Malcolm dent lived there for quite
a long time and raised a family there
and was apparently not you know I guess
he was scared of it but it wasn't enough
to like drive him out of it well this is
the thing that's kind of stamped me out
of what you're saying though but he said
that he didn't really believe in any
paranormal stuff but I saw this yeah how
do you see all this no he said before he
moved over for yeah he later said cuz
like I said I saw an interview with him
on one of the documentaries that I was
watching on YouTube he said essentially
the house kind of like he didn't use
these words but he was saying that it
kind of like personalized the things
that it would do like to the person like
I don't know if like it would do what
you were most afraid of or or because
he's like some people would come there
and not experience anything but it's
like maybe it just had to do something
was like your personality or your okay
beliefs or something like that like it
would kind of he said he said he talked
about the house as though it was as
though it was a conscious entity in Star
Wars terms what they're saying is that
the place was strong with the dark side
yeah that's essentially when you go in
there and you might have visions you
might have a paranormal [ __ ] yeah or
maybe nothing will happen maybe he's
just saying it depends on the person
he's just saying yeah he's just saying
that it's very tailored to the person
was strong with the dark
yeah I don't [ __ ] doubt it man maybe
mammoth was strong with the dark side
but I don't know cuz that phenomenon I
started before I actually got there yeah
I'd like to go back we'll have to do
that one of these days it's like maybe
we should do like we should do like a
Kickstarter or like for a little act to
go back to mammoths and like do I don't
know if they would let me get one we'll
take a donor or something or a patron
with us yeah I'm like we can sleep there
yeah I mean it was is it for sale or
rent or sale I can find out here's the
thing I'm looking at the pictures of it
and I go that's it yeah I think the the
address has changed slightly because I
think to changed the numbering on the
buildings yeah maybe they added more and
they or they knock some down they
knocked him down and already numbered
him but I got to talk to Louis Louis was
of course an adult during that time yeah
and she would help me figure it out a
little bit better if anybody want it has
the money and wants to go back to
Mammoth yeah because I'd be curious yeah
I've never been in California you might
be able to make that happen we gotta see
the people that owned it you know if
they're up to that yeah it's like hey we
had some haunting [ __ ] here can we just
like we don't have to stay like one
night or so there are a couple of nights
maybe oh you want to see there for a
couple days and see if anything happens
yeah nothing happens we just party there
yeah that works too it's win-win yeah I
need to want to go during the ski season
yeah so if you wanted to skate you could
ski where you were there yeah I wouldn't
I'm not a ski I don't either I'd I would
break both my legs my arms my neck I
gotta sit up there and just kind of
[ __ ] relive the past as I bring it
back I would just like to sit in the
snow and like drink hot chocolate on a
sunny Dookie like I said I'd break every
bone in my body
it's klutzy as I am but yeah so Malcolm
dent he's like even though you know all
this paranormal [ __ ] was happening and
like even people that visited him like
experienced similar like poltergeist
type activity it didn't stop him from
like living there for quite a long time
looking after well Jimmy Page owned it
but he's like I said he wasn't usually
there so he essentially was like living
in this out in the house of his family
he said really the most annoying
thing was all the people that were
making pilgrimages to Valeska Neve
Aleister Crowley because of its you know
notoriety
so he's like we get all these people
like hanging out like by the house and
trying to break in and all this other
kind of stuff because of the houses
reputation he's like so we had to have
like all these like super actual locks
and everything on the house to keep him
from breaking in so that was like the
biggest pain in the ass he thought so
yeah so while Jimmy Page owned it like I
said he didn't spend a great deal of
time there but he was trying to restore
it back to not necessarily how it would
have looked when Crowley lived there but
how he imagined it might have looked and
curly lived there I guess like he was
trying to kind of get back to that
period but he also hired an artist named
Charles pace to do some kind of two
murals on the walls that were like a
cult kind of murals and things like that
now after a while the house was actually
ended up being put on the market again
in 1991 it was put on the market for
250,000 pounds at this point it was
bought by a couple named Ronald on
Annette MacGillivray they bought it in
1992 now they said even though dent had
been living there like Jimmy Page and
Oded and stuff like that I guess he
hadn't really been in it for a while
because when the mcgillivray is brought
bought it they said it was pretty much a
dump
um for almost a half a million dollars
yeah quarter million quarter million
yeah fifty fifty two hundred fifty
thousand pounds pounds I thought that I
thought a pound was about two dollars
well it depends and like that like I
said I don't remember what the exchange
rate wasn't in 90s so I don't really
know so basically they had to strip
everything out to the bare walls they
had to put a new roof on it and all this
other stuff they ended up turning it
into a hotel so it was a hotel for a
little while
they asked Annette MacGillivray if she
had ever experienced any mysterious
occurrences while they lived at Valeska
house she said absolutely none I am a
non-believer and didn't listen to all
that rubbish we had a great time there
so they lived there for quite a while
and ran it as a hotel
Ronald actually died in 2002 but a
net-like
lived quite a bit longer however while
they were living there I found this very
interesting article that was in Glasgow
Sunday mail it dated March 2000 March
2000 so apparently there was this BBC
film crew and they were going to the
house to film a documentary about
Aleister Crowley which is called the
other Loch Ness monster it's actually on
YouTube I watched it earlier today so
you can watch it for free now this
article says that this film crew when
they went there they had all kind of
scary paranormal [ __ ] happen I don't
know if this stuff really happened to
them if they were trying to hype the
documentary or what because the people
that live there at the time because the
mikulov rays were still living there in
2000 but this croute film crew
apparently went there filming the
documentary and all kind of horrible
should happen so now the film producer
who was making the documentary he like
asked the priest and the minister and
stuff like that to bless at the place he
didn't really believe in it but he said
I'm just like covering all the bases or
whatever but evidently when the film
crew went there they had all kind of
like equipment failures they got
attacked by a plague of beetles which I
thought that was kind of neat and they
all started having nightmares about
Aleister Crowley like the same dreams or
so they said like a bunch of them said
they have the same dreams any details on
what the tree not really they just kind
of said they had James are coming like
what drop is nutsack tea-bagged by Le
Cirque Reyes omnisexual [ __ ]
come on when is that
with his shorn nothing with his short
that's a goddamn Pharaoh [ __ ]
headdress on I know I love that picture
of him with this freaky [ __ ] he
was yeah yeah well yeah he seemed like
kind of fun though it's like he probably
was hilarious like I said he sounds like
he's be fun to party with yeah he's
gonna you know his PR was all ominous
but that's how he that's how he made
second you know that's how he made his
reputation yeah
meat maybe he's probably [ __ ]
hilarious I'm sure but I feel like he
was like doing the same kind of [ __ ]
that like you know a lot of guys would
do it yeah like heavy metal bands and
stuff like that like we're so evil you
know what I mean and then like you hang
out with him awesome probably like Ozzy
that's kind of what I'm yeah that's kind
of I'm saying that he was kind of like
that type of date right so yeah so they
also this film crew apparently they took
like a bunch of pictures around Valeska
house and all of them were ruined by a
ghostly fog also they were doing a late
night shoot in the graveyard opposite
the house which i think is still there
like I have pictures of it and while
they were doing that like they had like
all the you know the krieg lights or
whatever they call those and they
exploded so like in like showered glass
all over the crew fuses burned out
camera stands fell over as I said a
bunch of members of the team had
nightmares about curly one crew members
mobile phone kept ringing intermittently
with that warning and another's alarm
clock kept going off at exactly the same
time dragging yeah it's like a medieval
[ __ ] it was the time of the axe murder
you guys yeah so as I said before they
also said they were attacked by a beetle
infestation now why specifically it was
a beetle infestation the the producer of
the documentary had a theory he said it
said curly and another guy in Paris I'm
presuming he means Mathers were sending
magical spells to each other I guess
through the mail in one spell Crowley's
dogs died which curly did mention early
in his diary and they were besieged by a
strange kind of beetle that could not be
identified by the Natural History Museum
as we were interviewing a man about that
incident the crew were overrun by
beetles they were swarming around the
cameras crawling over the lenses and
banging off the lights they also made a
weird shrieking noise you could hear it
on our soundtrack I know exactly what it
should have been a straightforward shoot
took 14 hours when I was in California
we had those Beatles or a Beatles
similar that's called a Japanese beetle
yeah and they were kind of brown with
white stripes on them and they would
make that
yeah grab him as a little kid try to
hold him and he would [ __ ] vibrate
and make that [ __ ] me yeah be
probably some kind of Japanese beetle
yeah yeah wait you know how in
California got him because they came in
in [ __ ] [ __ ] man so [ __ ] yeah I
mean stuff that came from Japan they're
like an invasive they're like an
invasive species yeah we have some bugs
like that too what a boy those big like
cicada things and cicadas I think I've
been here forever and all those other
kind of what are those other big bugs
that like fly around here that like make
that [ __ ] kind of noise we have all
the bugs in Florida pretty ones that I
haven't seen in a long time some of the
kid those big [ __ ] black grasshoppers
but yeah yellow wouldn't it yeah I used
to see him all the time
yeah would the in fact my grandmother's
yard they were like every summer that
would be yeah and everywhere and she
would have to go out there and pluck him
off her plants that had something to do
it was a kind of a locust it was a kind
of a grasshopper that [ __ ] got
roided-out from bad conditions and it
was summers were hotter back then I mean
I know people want to go on this global
warming but I was a kid I remember the
[ __ ] summers in Mississippi just
being [ __ ] ungodly hot and that's
when we saw those black grasshoppers it
had something to do with fields being
destroyed yeah I mean like crops going
bad haven't seen it in a long time the
last time I saw one of those was about
five years ago
no no longer than about seven years ago
- just one of them when I was working
out at a bar in one time yeah yeah
working with the horses as the last time
seeing one yeah black I haven't seen
yellow wings and there was like it was
red on him Tim red and yellow they're
very they're very like colorful and
they're evil they're really they're
largely aggressive getting near them
they start flapping their wings and
everything's like they're yeah Jackie
like they're poisonous they're well
they're like as big as your hand yeah
they're not yours honest though they're
just big ass act like they're poisonous
yeah yeah well that coloring is just
kind of like they're just like look I'm
dangerous mine yeah the attack yeah they
do I didn't see one of those in a while
though right
so apparently so like I said this
documentary action
did get made because I saw it but
apparently they this documentary when it
was first being made her a few years
before when they were like thinking
about making it the producer of it
actually asked Oliver Reed and asked him
to narrate it and Oliver Reed would not
because he was like superstitious about
the house apparently that's that's what
they producer said so after the death of
Ronald MacGillivray the guy that owned
the house like I said the Megillah
breeze had run it as a hotel
they put bull Eskin house up for sale
again now the new owners were a Dutch
family now they did not want any
publicity they converted it back into a
private residence they used it like for
a holiday house they didn't live there
all the time they just kind of went
there for holidays so they kept
anonymous they didn't really want any
publicity about it in 2009 that was
about a two acre plot of land that was
put on the market for 176 thousand
pounds they actually had plans drawn up
to build a 3-bedroom log house on it
that was like and there was also some
you got like some shoreline of like Loch
Ness but I don't think that was ever
done now in 2015 on December 23rd only
two days before Christmas at
approximately 1:40 p.m. there was a
motorist on the a82 road reported flames
and smoke coming from Bell Eskin house
by the time that fire the firefighters
got there 60% of the building had
already been incinerated flames rising
up to 20 feet high
the firefighters therefore were forced
to kind of just try to put out the what
they could like even though a lot of the
house had already been destroyed what
ended up happening there was apparently
no one in the house the guy who owned
the house I think his wife and daughter
had gone out shopping and then when they
came back like the house was burning
down they think that it started in the
kitchen they don't particularly think
that moon was arson you know no one was
hurt or anything like that but the house
is pretty much destroyed and there's
pictures of it all over the place the
roof is entirely gone it's just a
complete mess so
then in 2009 at the end of July or 2019
rather two buildings on the same plot
because that it's not just the house
there's like other little outbuildings
and stuff those two buildings were
partially destroyed by fire as well now
those two fires they do suspect that
that's arson although they never have
caught the person that did it so they're
still you know they're still like you
know police are like if you have any
information bla bla bla and everything
like that now the Luskin house was
actually bought by the bull eScan house
foundation s CIO in 2019 and they are
planning to completely restore it back
to the way it was and they're going to
open it to the public presumably as a
museum which is kind of neat so they're
looking for like donations and stuff
like that they have a website I think
it's just bull s kin house org and they
just started the restoration like a
month ago and there's a pretty long it's
not really a documentary but it's just
like film of the guy like walking around
the ruins and like saying what they're
gonna do with it and stuff because I
watched some of it so I kind of hoped
that they you know can get it it's it is
like a like a part of history and it
would be kind of cool if they got it all
restored and people could go see it
here's my theory what's that if anything
was paranormal had happened there it
wasn't so much because of the [ __ ]
the house it was the people in the house
she had a lot of spiritually active
people
yeah well that were involved in the you
know the main in paranormal and you know
mystical type things and maybe that
caused some phenomena to happen but it's
not necessarily that location yeah it's
just the people at that location may
have done it now some other people came
in later and reported some things maybe
some of that was hoax
maybe some of that was up people had
psyched themselves up based upon the
history of the place and then caused it
to happen you know I feel like once a
place has a reputation come on - yeah
it's like snowballs it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy because people
go there like expecting something to
happen which brings kind of certain
psychic energy to it no that might or
either that or they're just like
interpreting like
stuff that they wouldn't even notice
yeah my attorney says it is not
paranormal as paranormal because they're
expecting this house to be haunted it
all depends on who it is who's there I'd
have to see it yeah and all of you in
the audience would have to be there to
see it for yourself in order to make
that kind of Judge it's like it's hard
to just take one person's word for it
because even if the person wasn't lying
necessarily they could have been
mistaken I mean there could have been
like a lot of other or though maybe some
[ __ ] happened there yeah you know maybe
some things happened there you know even
if it didn't it's like I just find the
history of the house really interesting
yeah all the [ __ ] about Crowley I'm like
why he picked it and like what he did
there and stuff so it's like even you
know I just I just think all the stories
about it or cool whether they're true or
not you know name is people [ __ ] do
weird [ __ ] yeah cuz it's like I just
like like weird history type [ __ ] like
that even if there was nothing
supernatural involved alright so I think
we've gone on long enough about Valeska
in house and the history thereof shut it
down yet okay well before you shut it
down like to say hey if you guys liked
the show please hit us up on patreon
yeah
every dollar counts at this point we're
looking for patrons yep and it will help
us produce shows like I said we're on
four shows a week now yeah you know
maybe maybe one day we'll have a show
every day yeah I don't know if I want to
do that to myself yeah baby work you've
been working hard but it's like you know
what I mean you know I I do enjoy doing
the shows you know it's like I have
other stuff that I do that I enjoy also
but you know I do enjoy doing these so
yeah remember if you like the show like
share subscribe tell everybody about us
like anybody that you know that you
think would be into this kind of [ __ ]
you know tell them about us and maybe
they'll dig it to you and like I said if
you'd like to you financially support
the show go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
press calm and there's a button in the
sidebar that goes to a PayPal account if
you'd like to give a one-time donation
as some of our people do we've got some
good one-time donations that is also
very much appreciated like I said every
dollar helps go store the show goes
store we don't like go around by and
code
hookers without anything like that it's
like we pay me go there for free wait
wait a coconut curse for free he's like
coming out on me but yes I've got a talk
[ __ ] you know we get that [ __ ] for free
that was a good one yeah that's another
good shirt
I get that [ __ ] for free coconut coconut
yeah we we use it for you know just
regular bills we use that for you know
just employing the show all of that auto
repair yeah oh you guys but yeah well
these the cars are running now you know
fourteen hundred dollars later right
around Christmas - yeah but yeah so
anyway that will do it for episode 177
the first episode the first official
episode of 2020 the year that's like not
even real it's like the surreal [ __ ]
year we're in the Roaring Twenties I
guess so it sounds so much better yeah
okay I sound like I'm in the future well
we are in the future yeah but yeah okay
so we will see you guys next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]